he's going to get a lot of fastballs
tonight because that is the weapon du
jour of right-hander dustin may the
23-year-old third year dodger one in
three
in his
career against the san diego pod race
he's got to win in a loss most recently
at seattle on monday a tough luck loser
despite throwing the ball well and
striking out eight through five innings
of work may rounds out a series this
weekend that has featured nothing but
type a
quality starting pitching well you get
the number five
you get dustin may throwing a hundred
go get him right off he has a sinker a
fourth seamer a cutter and a curve ball
padres in the uh
road uniforms with the brown tops and
the sand pants i think for only the
third time this season grisham waiting
on a 1-2 from dustin may the pitch is on
the outside corner strike three call
first strike out of the ball game for
dustin may so two out to the base is
empty for manny machado he did not have
a hit last night for the first time this
season against the dodgers grounds to
seeger and with a broken bat that will
be out number three so a one two three
first for dustin may who has been
getting mostly strikeouts and ground
balls so far this season he got a
strikeout and two ground balls in the
top of the first he and the dodgers will
have their hands full tonight because
it's no no joe on the mound for the san
diego padres who in his second start of
the season and after 8
205 games in franchise history authored
the padres first ever
no-hitter a few weeks ago
and he's got a plus fastball and he has
a great feel on the mound he can spin
the ball really well cutter slider curve
ball
one and one coming and that one is swung
on and lifted in the air out to center
field fairly deep grisham there in front
of the warning track in left center to
make the catch
and two away from musgrove here in the
bottom of the first there's a 1-1
this one is popped up
short center field grisham coming in
he's there to make the catch
that will end the inning
cronenberg strikes out swinging
that's the second strikeout for may five
up five down there's two gun and tommy
fam coming up
this is a left turn sharp i mean that is
tight and a beauty i mean may would be a
number one or number two in 90 of the
teams out there two balls one strike
here's the pitch and pham swings hits
the ground ball slowly to third turner
charges has time takes his time and the
throw to first in plenty of time i think
fam may have pulled up about midway
between holmen first
he is walking slowly off the field he's
not even going to make it to the dugout
before the trainer gets there
so tommy pham injured running to first
base on a ground ball very odd been a
kind of a rough run to start the year
for tommy
as he is removed bases loaded and one
out no score bottom of the second inning
with one out now it'll be austin barnes
3-2
and barnes reaches out sends it into
right field it drops in front of mateo
that's going to score at least one
what a fine played appearance by austin
barnes
he was convinced he was going to get
another slider looked away and dumped it
into right field to drive in a score
professional bat here 3-2 and a very
tough slider here off the plate too
close to take the dodgers have struck
first they've got a one-nothing lead
trying to keep it at just one run bases
loaded two outs a ball and two strikes
on mookie bats muskrove ready and the
pitch is grounded to tatis fernando
charges goes the short way and they will
force barnes out at second to end the
inning so the dodgers had the bases
loaded nobody out they get just the one
run on one hit there was an error and
they left three we'll go to the third
inning at dodgers stadium now he's
falling behind three and one to seeger
who lines one into right field for a
base hit and that's going to roll into
the corner that's going to be at least a
double procedure he's rounding second
he's on his way to third here comes
seeger and he's going to make it
standing up
a leadoff triple for corey seeger here
in the third inning
what the wide wide world of sports is
going on here clearly a fair ball and
clearly not interfered with all balls
down this right field corner can be
tedious at times and mateo had to come a
long way he was playing more so towards
right center and then tried to pick it
up with the bare hand while it's rolling
which is a no-no and there's a base hit
by justin turner that drives in seeger
two-nothing l.a in a rare fast but here
from musgrove to the wrong guy 0-1 and
he's waiting for him a contact guy
hard contact here it's been a battle for
musgrove tonight runners lead at all
three stations for the dodgers being the
bottom of the third inning here's the
2-2 barnes reaches for the curve ball
grounds into short fernando pats it in
the glove throws to first high but
hosmer able to go up and come down with
it to end the inning
another off-target throw from the padre
infield but no damage done the dodgers
get just one more
so here's fernando tattis jr who bounced
to third in his first at-bat here's the
two-two pitch and that one is swung on
hit in the air out to deep right center
field betts is going back he is at the
wall it's gonna go
fernando homers again
his fifth in his last 11 at bats against
the dodgers and the padres are within
one here in the fourth i mean you want
to talk about a prime time player you
cannot take your eyes off him you can't
stop talking about him baseball royalty
98 in on his hands
and just explodes
kim 209 a home run a couple of rbis and
the pitch swung on and missed strike
three
tenth strikeout for dustin may
the last three in a row one out nobody
on in the six though he's been able to
reach back and get that little extra
when it's been needed
may on two and two with two out to
machado
he bloops it into short left retreating
at seeger he's got it and that'll in the
inning
what a night for dustin may and sheldon
noisy is batting for dustin may
noisy on the first pitch with a fly ball
to left field and deep and guards
sheldon noisy on the first pitch he sees
a pinch hit home run and the dodgers
take a 3-1 lead a terrific swing and a
great sound taylor got the board on an
error took a call third strike and flied
to center
taylor with a drive well hit to center
field
and that one's gone welcome back to the
starting lineup chris taylor a fastball
away just stays through it gets deep and
sensational approach so down seven to
one in the seventh the bases are loaded
one out victor caratini at the plate
ball to no strikes to carratini here's
the pitch he swings lines one to left
that's a base hit one run will score
cronenworth is rounding third he's on
his way and he will score a two-run
single for carratini i hope he didn't go
anywhere it's seven to three here in the
seventh bad speed at first myers ground
ball to third turner throws to second
out at second on the first double play
nice turn by noisy dave diego scores two
runs first one coming to haas swung on
and line through the right side to base
it tatis will come in to score manny
stops at second base it's a seven to
four game here in the eighth oh and two
to mateo
back up the
middle noisy to seeger not in time for
the double play another run scores
the 1-2
and tati sends the ball to left field to
base hit
this young man is just incredible
now trent grisham comes with a plate
first pitch coming he swings hits it on
the ground the left side it gets through
turner and a base hit guaranteed hits
third he's going to come home and score
and tatisse will make it all the way
around to third it is a seven to six
game in the top of the ninth here's
machado tying run 90 feet away with one
gun and manny sends a base hit back up
the middle
tati scores this game is tied at seven
[Applause]
two on one out first pitch to haas
fastball swung on hit well out to center
field peter's going back he is just in
front of the warning track that'll get a
run home he makes the catch tatis tags
tati scores and for the first time
tonight the padres have a lead and los
angeles is down to its final out tonight
the pitch is a curveball grounded slowly
up the middle right at tatis he steps on
second that is the ball game and that is
a hell of a winner for the padres as
they take the dodgers down eight to
seven in 11.